like anyone the south of the MC you mess
up sometimes and the Cass of Captain
Marvel was no exception
despite seasoned actors and Oscar
winners filling the movies roster lines
were forgotten blocking was totally
bungled and goofiness got the best of
the stars more often than you might
think
brie Larson carried the weight of
Captain Marvel on her shoulders and
spent months preparing to play the
high-flying heroine as best as she
possibly could she devoted hours of her
days to working out in the gym stuck to
a strict diet and even visited the US
Air Force Academy for some up and close
personal priming
but when Larson acquired all that
newfound strength and knowledge and
know-how she apparently lost an
important basic scale multiple times
during filming Larson got mixed up on
the direction she was supposed to go and
what she was meant to do with her body
[Music]
Larson again gets directionally confused
while filming a fight scene with Talos
actor Ben Mendelsohn who also could have
used to helping hand in the blocking
department the to rehearse that tussle
one way but when they got in front of
the cameras everything was backwards
because the best things come in threes
loccent topsy shenanigans off by
barreling down a hallway before
realizing that she's running in the
wrong direction
rarely do actors nail a scene in one
take their performance may be spot-on
but the lighting might be totally wonky
maybe the set design is impeccable and
the mood exactly right but the line
delivery isn't seamless like we said
before no one in the movie industry is
immune to mistakes for the Captain
Marvel crew though one scene didn't just
have a single hiccup it went wrong in
almost every way imaginable the
sequencing question is the one in which
brie Larson's Carol Danvers Ben
Mendelsohn's Talos Samuel Jackson's Nick
Fury and lashana Lynch's Maria Rambo
escaped from the Kree warriors and the
Star Force Squad in pursuit of Marvel's
hidden laboratory that served as a
refuge center for display scrolls on
screen the seamless flawless but one
take turned hilariously disastrous we're
talking broke kitten lighting mishap
whole casts breaking character
disasterous look at this unbridled mess
worst maybe most hilarious oh you bet if
you thought the blooper featuring a real
cat playing goose was rib-tickling there
are plenty of silly I'll take so find
the cast interacting with a fake feline
to one take shows Samuel Jackson looking
half sad half bemused to find out he's
shooting with a standing cat especially
since he keeps getting fur on his nose
in another leshawna Lynch can't keep it
together while Jackson hauls our focus
and keeps talking to it as if it was a
real deal thus not all the feline fun
the actors had on set in a third I'll
take real arsons Carol throws a prop cat
of Ben Mendelsohn's talos who is deathly
afraid of goose since the cubby creature
is actually a shape-shifting bug at the
mention holding alien known as a fleur
kin when she tosses a kitty at talos
well see for yourselves
remember that scene in the film where
Phil Coulson and Nick Fury team up to
find out what the heck is going on after
Carol Danvers crash lands on earth you
know I said she destroys a blockbuster
and brings back a pack of Scrolls
trailing behind her your recall that the
dynamic duo was attacked by squirrels
and this soon revealed that the Coulson
sitting in the passenger seat of Fury's
car isn't the shield rookie at all
he's really a scroll whose shape-shifted
into Coulson the to fight for control of
the steering wheel with fury ultimately
winning
deliberately crushes the car and kills
the scroll that scene might have been
wild to watch but the process of filming
must have given the casting crew a
heaping helping of headaches if this
version of the same scene is any
indication of course we aren't privy to
their medical histories but judging by
the Captain Marvel gag reel it looks
like both brie Larson and Ben Mendelsohn
might have a serious case of sweaty
palms Larson and Mendelsohn continuously
drop things during shooting ruining
takes but showing that beneath all those
flashy prosthetics and CGI effects
they're just as human as their fans they
all take reel finds clumsiness getting
the best of Larson while filming the
scene in which Carol Danvers retrieves a
tesseract from Marvel's Laboratory
orbiting earth slippery fingers played
Mendelssohn when he was trying to
perform a cold trick with Talos
susceptor he can be seen tossing it up
in the air ever so slightly but having
trouble grabbing hold of the darn thing
when it comes back down each time he
attempts to move Mendelssohn fumbles and
the staff falls to the ground after
bleeding repeatedly and dropping his
props over and over again on the Captain
Marvel set Ben Mendelsohn brought her
steady streak to an end with a rousing
rendition of the 1960s tune released me
apparently because he was worn out from
filming and just wanted to rap for the
day peel off his facial prosthetics
scrub away all his green scroll makeup
and relax after he ends a take
Mendelssohn declares a traumatic tone
but no one answers back he starts
singing the opening lines of 1966 track
popularized by Engelbert Humperdinck
because why not despite that not
happening at this round of shooting
inevitably ended with Mendelssohn's wish
finally being granted and he was indeed
released we're just happy that on this
particular day he led his golden voice
be heard check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]